[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALICIA PATERSON: Hi, everyone,
and welcome to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars from Google Cloud
that we host every Tuesday.
Just a reminder, you
can ask questions
on the platform at any point.
We have Googlers standing
by to answer them.
So let's get started.
Hi, I'm Alicia Paterson.
I'm a program delivery
consultant with Apigee,
which is part of Google Cloud.
And I get to work with big
brands across the planet
and help them leverage
APIs to deliver
a impact in their businesses.
Our webcast today is being
co-presented with Walgreens,
so I'm delighted
to be joined today
by Erin Neus-Cheong,
who's the director
for core digital products
and innovation at Walgreens.
Great to have you with us.
ERIN NEUS-CHEONG:
Thanks, Alicia.
ALICIA PATERSON: So
today we're going
to spend a little bit of time
talking about what it means
to build API products,
and then Erin's
going to talk
about how Walgreens
has been able to use APIs
to extend their assets
into developer ecosystems.
And then that'll be followed by
responding to your questions,
so let's jump into it.
So what do we mean when we
talk about APIs as products,
and how can productizing
APIs provide opportunities
for business?
This can be a difficult
concept for product people
to get their head
around, as at best, APIs
are seen as points of technical
integration and as at worse,
IT jargon.
I have a simple example
from the insurance business
that I find product
professionals can often
relate to, and it helps
illustrate the ability for APIs
to extend into new
channels of opportunity
while also extending a
better customer experience.
So no one really enjoys
shopping for insurance.
It's one of those
necessary things
that we have in our lives.
Insurance companies have a tough
time creating a great customer
experience because the
times you typically
engage with an insurance company
is when you have to pay them
a bunch of money
to buy insurance
or when you make a claim
because something that you hoped
wouldn't happen just happened.
So I was thinking about this
recently because I bought
a drone, like an
unmanned aerial vehicle,
and I was concerned
that it might fall out
of the sky from time to time
and land on something expensive.
So I went shopping
for insurance,
and I found this product offer
by a large, multinational
insurance company.
And they make the
product available
through the traditional high
commission agent network
as well as directly online.
It was like $800 for a
million dollars of coverage
that lasted a year.
I thought it was a bit
pricey for me, probably
a bit pricey, too, for more
than the half a million
people that bought consumer
drones in the US last year.
And then I found a mobile
app, more of a niche insurance
offering.
When you launch this
app, it draws a map,
drops a pin where
you are, and says
if you want to fly your drone
for the next hour anywhere
in that radius, then
it costs like $20
or something for a million
dollars of coverage,
which was a much better
offering for a casual flyer.
And that made me think.
The insurance
company's core business
is assessing an
underwriting risk
and putting a price on that,
and obviously having a margin
where they make their business.
Had they been API first
and productized to the API,
it would have allowed them
to extend their core business
to power this app,
the one that I found,
and indeed, many others like it.
And what's more, if they
had APIs to quote and sell
their drone
insurance, they could
give it to drone
manufacturers who
then could build it directly
into their product experience.
When you use the
app or whatever tool
you use to control your
drone, one of the options
might include purchasing
insurance for that flight.
And surely there's
no better experience
than not having to worry about
going and getting insurance
before you can go
flying with your drone.
Instead, you can just fly your
drone with the peace of mind
that you can purchase insurance
for that particular flight
if you need to.
And it also occurred to me that
the insurance company today
uses, obviously, a lot of data
to inform its risk assessment
and pricing.
However, typically
the only data it's
able to collect when
running its business
is when someone buys a policy
or when they make a claim.
Whereas if they were to
productize to the API
and serve applications
like the one that I found,
then they could
also have visibility
of how often people
fly their drones
and where they fly their
drones and for how long--
data that could significantly
enrich their ability
to assess that insurance risk.
Productizing the API, creating
an API to quote and sell
drone insurance,
and then offering it
to an external ecosystem
of app developers and drone
manufacturers would not
only extend their product
to a much greater
reach, it would also
give them richer data with
which to make their underwriting
assessment.
Not to mention, they could
also use those APIs, then,
to power their traditional
agent network and their website.
So what does
productizing an API mean?
There are many aspects
that we might talk about,
but for this webcast,
we're just going
to focus on these three items.
So outside-in means
developing a strong focus
on the external
business or user need
and making sure
your organization
connects that perspective
directly to development work.
We'll talk more on
that in a moment.
Speed to market recognizes the
cost of software and supporting
infrastructure is lower now
than it ever has been before,
thanks to growth in
Cloud driving down
infrastructure costs,
software frameworks
with built-in foundations
that speed development,
and open source platforms allow
for maximum collaboration.
Because of this, the manner
in which software is built
needs to change to modern agile
practices with a strong focus
on removing obstacles
to fast delivery.
The digital products are
never really finished, right?
Because there's always some
new technology or new device
that your customers expect
to engage you across.
Iterative delivery asks that
you take an iterative product
delivery approach to your APIs--
that you have a
product backlog, you
make regular ongoing
improvements to them over time,
the same as you would for your
website or your mobile apps
or indeed any other
product that you might own.
So each of these
we can break down
into further supporting ideas--
a couple of which
I'll talk about now--
but also much is covered
in our "Complete Guide
to API Products" eBook,
the link for which
we'll provide a little bit
later on in this webcast.
So lets look more
closely at outside-in.
Outside-in is a mindset.
It's a design
philosophy supported
by organizational constructs,
such as team and role
definitions and software
development methodologies.
It moves a problem domain
from an IT question
of exposing data or
other assets instead
to the question of how that data
will be used from a consumption
perspective.
Traditionally, IT
teams think about APIs
from an exposure point of view--
we can just expose a
service and be finished.
This brings with it a risk
of surfacing complexity
since the people
who build solutions
on your backend systems
are close to their systems
and [INAUDIBLE] in
their idiosyncrasies.
If your API development
team consists of just
your backend
developers, then you
run the risk of exposing your
complexity with your data,
whether it be complicated call
outs to disparate services
or an assumed understanding
of the underlying data
architecture.
Exposing complexity creates
friction for the developers
who will consume your APIs,
slowing down their adoption
and their ability
to build solutions
on top of your assets.
However, thinking about it from
the end user's point of view
leads to better results
for the business.
Apigee's most successful
customers start from the user,
thinking about what the user's
experience will be like,
and working
backwards from there.
Providing the application
developer with great APIs
reduces the complexity they face
in creating new applications.
The application developer
is free to focus
on user experience and iterate
on a few different designs.
The API team makes this
possible by providing
easy to use APIs with consistent
interfaces and security
patterns.
The API team builds
an API facade
on the existing services
based on an understanding
of the application
developer's needs
and abstracting away
the complexities.
One way to ensure that you
bring an outside-in perspective
to development is to make
sure that your development
team includes a product
owner, ideally a product
manager for the API,
or the relevant product
owner for that
business area, someone
who is close to the
needs of the users
and the app developers that
are creating software for them.
So packaging up an
API as a product
means considering
the outside-in design
and making it easy for
those consuming developers
to find and use your APIs
to solve the software
problems that they
face, helping them
with things like
great documentation
that makes it clear what the API
does and how it might be used.
Like with e-commerce, your
goal is to make the experience
as frictionless as possible--
remove barriers to
discovery and adoption
by your app developers.
In the same way an
online retailer seeks
to remove unnecessary clicks
between a customer's purchase
decision and their check out,
in the API product world,
you should be
looking to minimize
the time it takes for
your app developers
to get to their first hello
world, their first use
of your APIs.
So what does an API product
experience look like?
I have a conceptual model
that presents a metaphor,
if you like, for the
API product experience
from an app developer's
perspective.
So for this metaphor,
I want you to imagine
that your 8-year-old
niece, it's her birthday,
and she's asked you
for a LEGO castle.
So you go down to
the LEGO store.
When you walk in, you see
rows of LEGO boxes on shelves.
So the whole catalog
is on display,
making it really easy
for you to quickly find
the box that has a
picture of a castle on it
that looks like
the kind of thing
you think she might enjoy.
When you look at the box, you
see that it says ages 6 to 65.
It describes the target
audience for the product.
It has pictures on the
box of what the completed
set will look like.
In fact, there are
pictures of other things
you can use the
contents to build--
they're like other use cases
for the contents of the box.
You're pretty sure
it's what she'll want,
but you're even more
sure when you see a glass
case on display nearby where
one has been assembled already.
And you can look
at that one, it's
like a reference
implementation for the product.
So confident it's exactly what
she'll love, you can buy it.
You're out of the store
within five minutes
knowing that you've solved
the problem that you have.
Now imagine that experience
built by someone close
to the backend that might
take and exposure approach,
like an inside out approach.
In that case, when you go
down to the LEGO store,
you can't walk
straight in, of course,
because you need to first have
an NDA and contract signed
to let you come into the store.
And then once you can
come into the store,
rather than seeing rows
of products on shelves,
you see buckets and buckets of
all different types of LEGOs
in all different types of color.
All the complexity
is on display here,
and now it's your
job to figure out
how you're going to assemble
all those pieces together
to make a castle.
You've got no choice but to
go and ask someone to help.
And they say, yeah, get
1,000 of the gray bricks
and 1,000 of the brown
bricks, whatever else,
and you're in there for ages.
And when you walk out, you have
this big bag of all this LEGO,
and you're still
not even sure how
it's going to come together to
create the thing that you need
to give to your niece in spite
of spending ages and ages
in the store.
So the outside-in
perspective would've
seen that a store full
of buckets of bricks
is too complex for folks looking
to buy a gift for their child.
As with APIs, to
create a great product,
it is important to bring
the outside-in perspective
to the development team.
So one organization that's
been able to do this
with great result is
Walgreens, and Erin is here
today to tell us a little
bit about that journey.
ERIN NEUS-CHEONG:
Thanks, Alicia.
So as you're probably
aware, Walgreens
is a very large and very
diverse organization.
And within the
company, we have a lot
of different businesses
operating independently
within the overall corporation.
So my team, the core digital
products team, our mission
is to create and
scale and operate
the products and features
that aren't aligned
to anyone's specific business,
but those that support and add
value across all
of our businesses.
And one very important
component of my team
is our third party
API program, which
is what I am excited to
talk to you about today.
So I've been in my current
role for just a few months now,
but I've been with Walgreens
for almost seven years now.
So I was there back in 2012 when
we launched our very first API,
and I remember it seemed
very novel at the time.
So I was reading a
tech blog and there
was a headline that said,
"The apocalypse is upon us,
Walgreens has an API."
So it might not
have always seemed
obvious from the
outside, but really
from inside the
organization, the conditions
were really right for us
to embark on this journey.
And there are, I think, three
key things that really set us
up for success to do that.
So the first thing
is that we had
a really strong foundational
digital strategy
and mobile strategy
that we're building off
of toward an API program.
Secondly, we had the right
mindset within the organization
to embrace disruption
and think about new
and better ways of doing things.
And third, we were in a stage
of maturity within e-commerce
where we were really developing
and building out the product
management discipline
fundamentally.
So the timing was really great.
And let me just walk, in
a little bit more detail,
through each of
those with you here.
So the first is our
API program strategy.
So at the time, we had
some very, very innovative,
first-to-market-type digital
solutions that we had come up
with, like the ability
to scan your pill bottle
and automatically refill
your prescription that way,
and the ability to,
[CLEARING THROAT] excuse me,
print photos directly from
your camera roll directly
into the Walgreens store.
And we came up with these
ideas and opportunities,
really, by just re-imagining
those core central value
proposition elements that we
had in our retail locations
and thought about how
they would manifest
as a great digital experience.
And then beyond building
out those capabilities,
just due to the nature of the
features that we had built,
we really had to connect
them from the very beginning
into our physical location.
So we had a really rich and
robust Omnichannel experience
from very early on.
And this was extremely powerful
for us, as you can imagine.
And kind of beyond
just connecting
our own digital
experiences, our leadership
in e-commerce at
the time realized
that it could be even more
powerful if we could unlock
those core capabilities
to an even wider audience
by connecting to this
broader developer ecosystem.
So the second piece that I
think was really critical
for us was having a business
that was the right opportunity
to pursue this
type of innovation.
And so we did have a
business-- photo, at the time,
was going through a
massive transformation.
If you're thinking back
to then, had very quickly
gone from a state where people
were developing rolls of film
from cameras to doing
digital photography.
And very quickly then,
even right through that,
into taking all of your photos
straight from your smartphone.
And coupled with the
smartphone photography
was this development
of hundreds,
if not thousands, of different
photo taking and editing
and collage apps
that were happening.
And then the output of that
being so easy to just, with one
click, share to social media.
So that was your entire
experience from capture
through editing to
sharing, and it sort of
had elbowed out this need to
print a physical product, which
had been the focal
point of taking photos,
in the not too distant past.
And so we were looking for
ways to solve that riddle.
And I give a ton of credit to
the head of our photo business
at that time-- is that he really
understood and appreciated
that this change wasn't
necessarily a problem for us.
It was actually a
really big opportunity,
and he embraced that and was
really excited to see what
a program like this could do.
And honestly, right now I think
that almost every industry
is being disrupted
in this kind of way--
ALICIA PATERSON:
Of course, yeah.
ERIN NEUS-CHEONG:
--so it would be
hard to even think of a business
that this kind of solution
couldn't be appropriate for.
So the third piece
for us, again,
was the fact that we
were really building out
this product management
discipline and way of thinking
within the organization.
And we kind of
looked at everything
as how do we manage this
thing in a product way?
And I've been in products
for a very, very long time,
and I'm accustomed to
identifying opportunities
as the things that form the
intersection of the features
that would specifically
drive value
for the business and the things
that the customer value is
coming from.
And what I think is really
interesting about managing
API's products is that it layers
on this third dimension, which
is the things that drive
value for the developer.
And in fact, it's really
different because the value--
we're used to driving
value for the customer,
but the value that you
drive for the customer
is actually indirect.
And so you spend your
time just thinking
about what the possibilities
could be for that opportunity
and then making the best
possible product that
meets the needs of the developer
to unlock that and manage
that customer experience.
ALICIA PATERSON:
Yeah, that's great.
ERIN NEUS-CHEONG: So
that's the outside-in
that you were talking
about earlier.
ALICIA PATERSON:
Of course, yeah.
ERIN NEUS-CHEONG: So the
example that you see here, we
thought about what our
problem statement was,
which is how do we reengage
these smartphone users
with photo printing?
And we looked at
our business value
component, which is we really--
we need to increase revenue
from photo services.
We need to get people
printing again,
and what we thought
the customers wanted--
which was a fun and
simple way to keep
doing those things
that they were really
enjoying but to potentially
layer on a very easy way
to have a physical
component of output
from what they had
created that captures
not just what they took the
photo of in the first place,
but the experience of
actually creating and having
this sort of social
environment in which they
were using their photos.
And so then we really
thought about the fact
that we needed that
partnership with the developers
because that's where
the customers were.
And we realized
that this could work
because we had a lot of
value that we could offer
to the developer community.
And so we embarked on
our very first API.
And as it turned out,
this formula that we had,
which was the right
strategy, the right mindset,
and the product management
approach, really worked for us.
And because we had created this
great product with that outcome
in mind, it was easy to use.
It had a great
feature set, there
was an opportunity
for earning revenue
from the developers, which was
actually pretty rare back then.
And the marketing opportunities
that came from a partnership
with the Walgreens brand,
we had tons of interest
in the program.
And in fact, just
in terms of scale,
we actually have had
over 200 integrations
just for our photo printing
API since we launched it.
ALICIA PATERSON:
That's a great result.
ERIN NEUS-CHEONG: And we've
seen a ton of benefits
from this API and the program
in general, specifically here.
There was a significant
amount of direct revenue
that started coming from this
channel, and still to this day,
is actually driving measurable
impact and influencing,
bringing photo back to being a
growth business for us again.
ALICIA PATERSON:
Yeah, that's awesome.
ERIN NEUS-CHEONG:
And secondly, we
have found that the
developer community is
very good at identifying
new ways and opportunities
to attract customers
back into wanting
to print, which is great.
And they're doing this
because we're giving them
these great tools and the
flexibility to problem
solve on their
own without having
the ideas have to come from us.
And then finally, I think
that this kind of partnership
has really helped the
industry as a whole
to become more innovative.
And some of the innovation
that's come out of that,
we've actually been able
to repurpose and bring
into our own digital
assets as well.
So one more comment
on this, honestly.
I'm telling the story
now as the perspective
of being leader of the team
that includes the API program.
But back then, I was not that.
I wasn't a mobile
product person.
I wasn't an API product person.
I was the photo product person.
And so it was really
difficult for me
to give up that
control of my customer,
that I had guarded so carefully,
to completely external parties
who were actually defining
parts of the customer journey.
But at the same time, it was
actually really liberating
because there were
things that I couldn't
do that maybe I would
have wanted to do
and I couldn't because
of brand constraints
or because of
resource constraints
technology constraints.
And a lot of these
partners that we had
didn't have the
same constraints,
and it was really
excited to see what they
could do with that freedom.
And really, at the
end of the day,
regardless of where the
customer journey started,
at the end of it, they were
walking into a Walgreens store.
And so they were getting
a really important part
of our customer journey
that was owned by us.
ALICIA PATERSON: Yeah,
that's wonderful.
ERIN NEUS-CHEONG: So over
the past five plus years,
we've continued to build out
our portfolio of API products,
and we've continued to
identify opportunities
to extend those core central
capabilities of Walgreens,
particularly in areas of
transition or disruption
in a way that's enticing
to the developer community.
So today we have this whole
portfolio of API products
that we manage.
For photo, we didn't
stop with prints.
So almost immediately after
we launched the printing API,
our developer partners
started approaching us
with ideas for other
types of products
that they'd like to
be able to create,
like greeting cards, posters,
canvases, photo books.
And this was really
great because
our organizational
expertise within Walgreens
was not necessarily creating
mobile photo product builders.
And we were really excited
because we had these products
that we could create.
We couldn't always get to
them, but we could actually
let our partners be
the ones to focus
on things like building the best
mobile photo collage creator.
And they were able
to actually launch
those products before
we could launch it
in our own mobile app.
So after photo, we moved
on into the pharmacy space.
Obviously this is big and
central to our business.
So we initially went out
with a prescription refill
and transfer API.
And obviously anything
that has to do
with pharmacy and Walgreens,
the scale and the reach
is so great that it's a very
appealing partnership for any
of our potential partners.
And specifically,
our large health
care provider
partners are motivated
to try to drive patients
to take their medications
in a timely fashion,
for example.
So any way they
can reduce friction
in the process of
getting the recommended
prescription into
a Walgreens store
to be filled without any
of those drop off points
that it would require from
actually physically making
someone go to a
separate experience.
And so a huge interest
in that program.
Beyond that, other
aspects of health
care as well, beyond
just prescriptions.
We went through a period
where we kicked off
a tremendous health care
innovation program, which
has continued on to this day.
One aspect of that was really
partnering, potentially,
with fitness device
tracking companies.
And so looking for ways
to engage in health care
and wellness outside of
just the medications,
this was a great opportunity.
So we actually launched what
we call our Balance Rewards
for healthy choices API, which
means that a customer can
actually sync up and
integrate their fitness
device with this API
and automatically
be rewarded with our
loyalty program points which
they can then apply toward
rewards within the company--
ALICIA PATERSON:
That's really cool
ERIN NEUS-CHEONG: --which
is really exciting.
So moving beyond
that, most recently
we've been spending a lot
of time working on shopping
and couponing experiences.
And so just kind of going
back to the mindset component,
retail shopping, deal
seeking is shifting
a lot right now in terms of
the way customers approach it.
And they're definitely, in
most cases, not coming straight
to walgreens.com to do
all of that research.
And so we need to find new
ways to get our experiences out
there where customers
are searching
and shopping and deal-seeking
to bring them back
into our network.
And so a couple of
things that we have,
number one is there's
a Digital Offers
API, which enables us
to showcase personalized
offers for customers which they
can then clip to their loyalty
account and have that
coupon automatically
be applied at checkout.
We also have an Add
to Cart API, so we're
able to actually transfer
a product directly
from any product experience
into a walgreens.com
cart for fulfillment
by our business,
so thinking a lot more there.
We do have a few more really
exciting things coming,
so definitely stay tuned.
And I just wanted
to add, as we take
a look at this whole portfolio
of APIs that we have here,
is that we weren't just
coming to the table
and saying, hey, let's build
an API out of the blue, right?
We were actually doing this in
a way to respond to the things
that the company was focusing
on and thinking about,
and again, especially
as these spaces
were going through a
lot of transformation.
But I think that
actually planning out
how to productize a
service as an external API
has helped us really get very
good at building our APIs to be
really flexible and scalable,
not just for external,
but for internal use as well.
And what's really great
is that our API team, both
on the product and
engineering side,
has gotten really, really good
at encouraging our developer
community within Walgreens
to think about this approach
and make things very
developer-friendly
from the beginning, even
if we aren't originally
intending it to surface it
outside of the organization.
So just as an example,
we had a vendor
who's responsible for
replenishing water
coolers in our store
locations, and they
wanted to use our store
locating service that we had
that we were using internally.
And using Apigee,
we were actually
able to open that up
to them very quickly
and easily to
accomplish that goal.
And so just one
final comment that I
want to make with respect
to this whole portfolio
is that on top of just building
the roadmap and the features
and building out
these capabilities,
we're constantly
focusing on how we
can make it more
developer-friendly and how,
as you mentioned
before, how important it
is to make that onboarding
process as smooth as possible.
Because we know we
have a lot of value
here that we can offer
to developer partners,
and we just don't want there
to be any obstacles to them
for getting onboard.
So just wanted to kind
of talk a little bit
about what I think has helped
us be successful managing
APIs as products.
And I know that
every organization
is a little different-- the
resources, the structure
is a little bit different.
But here's some of
the things that I
thought would be
applicable more broadly
and kind of what I think
makes our API product roadmap
a success within Walgreens.
So the first piece is that
we have a product roadmap.
So again, we manage it just
like any other product.
We have a backlog,
we have a roadmap.
We integrate with the digital
roadmap planning process
that we have across all of
our digital product teams.
And we participate
in an event that we
do quarterly, which is basically
a quarterly digital product
roadmap review,
and that includes
not just the digital
product team, but all
of our different core
business stakeholders
across the different
businesses--
IT partners, marketing partners.
And I think that
visibility into what we're
doing with our API program has
driven really great engagement.
Secondly, we have a really
great developer evangelist
who is actually a member
of our product team,
so he's an engineer and also
a product thinking person.
And I think that partnership
has been really, really critical
for us to be able to not
only think about the APIs
in a product way, but also for
him to be aware of what we're
bringing out into the market.
And beyond that, we have
really, really great tools
that we use that
help us effectively
manage the program so we
can spend as much time
as possible thinking
strategically and less
about the administrative
part of the job.
So we have our
Developer Portal, which
is the entry point for
the developer community
to come into our API program
and to interface with us.
Of course we have
Apigee, which allows
us to be a really good partner
to our developer community.
We have a pretty small team,
and we have a lot of partners.
We have over 300
partners right now.
And so Apigee does a
great job of making
that really seamless
and efficient
for us to managing across
that large portfolio,
and furthermore,
for us to get really
easy access into the data and
analytics around the program.
We also have a really
great central communication
tool that we use.
We use Basecamp,
so it helps anyone
who is interested in following
these things from set
up and launch of
these capabilities
as it goes through
different types of tasks,
some more technical or
less technical than others.
It's all in one
place, so it makes
it really seamless to track that
through from beginning to end.
And then finally, from
a tools perspective,
we recently launched more
of an Informational Portal
that's less technical
than our Developer Portal.
And this is something
that we think
is going to be helpful
both internally
and for our developer community
to be able to talk in more
value centric language about
what this API program really is
and the benefits
that it can drive.
ALICIA PATERSON: Yes,
connecting more directly
with actual value.
ERIN NEUS-CHEONG: Absolutely.
And so last but
definitely not least,
we put a big focus on, as
you do with any product,
defining what success
looks like for that product
and being able to report
out the performance
against the key
metrics that we've
defined from the beginning.
And as interest
in the program has
grown beyond digital
product management,
we've started actually putting
together more business centric
dashboards, and sometimes in
partnership with our marketing
teams as well to really
kind of polish this
and to be able to very clearly
articulate the business
value and the success
that these programs have
and that they can have.
So hopefully that
helps shed some light
on how we manage our API
products within Walgreens.
And I'm excited to answer a few
questions about the program,
so thank you for having me.
And definitely I
would suggest also,
if I don't have time to
answer all the questions,
you can always reach
out to our team
through our Developer Portal
at developer.walgreens.com.
ALICIA PATERSON:
Thank you, Erin.
It's always great to hear
your story because it's
great to hear an
organization like Walgreens
create this platform
and then build
an ecosystem of participants.
They're actually adding
value to your business,
but also incentivizing them
to continue to contribute.
So it's such a great story.
I love sharing it with people.
So I did mention before,
we have some resources
I wanted to share with you.
So we have "The Complete
Guide to API Products eBook.
The link is available
on the screen
there, so I encourage
you to go and look.
There's a much deeper dive
there into how to build and run
API programs as API products.
And there's a microsite
that's around that
as well that's sort of dedicated
to additional information.
There's some customer
stories and blogs there.
And of course,
developer.walgreens.com
to get to Walgreens's
Developer Portal.
So now I'd ask you to please
stay tuned for the live
Q&A. We'll be back for that
in just less than a minute.
So thank you for some of the
questions I see rolling in.
So I'm showing some of
those on the screen,
and I'm going to ask questions,
and Erin will probably
respond for most of them.
So first question, Erin, how
do you manage the bureaucracy
within a large
organization like Walgreens
when looking to build
new API products
and expose additional services?
ERIN NEUS-CHEONG: Yeah, that is
definitely a big factor for us.
And to me, the key is really
always about relationships.
So I think that's one thing
that product managers are
trained to do really well
is to build relationships
across different parts
of the organization
and to actually speak a
lot of different languages,
so to speak.
And it's really important
to be able to communicate
not just what we're doing but
actually why we're doing it
and really lead with
the value proposition
and what the benefit is to
the organization by doing
and what we're unlocking
with this given
service or capability.
And beyond that, I think
the team has really
done a great job of building
subject matter expertise
and credibility.
And we make sure that we
have those trained experts
present throughout the
process, whether it's
trying to get a security
approval or some other part
of the process.
And building that trust with
all of our partners really
helps us move the path
forward through some
of that bureaucracy
that can be in place.
ALICIA PATERSON: And
of course and they
say that nothing breeds
success like success,
and you've had such
a successful story.
But to your point
earlier, being able to tie
what you have done back
to real demonstrated value
for the business, that gives
you a platform internally to go
and talk about your success.
All right, next question.
Were you able to
estimate or quantify
the assumed benefits of
the program of enabling out
to external developers prior
to going down this path?
ERIN NEUS-CHEONG:
Yeah, so it can
be really hard to do that
because you don't necessarily
control all aspects
of the market.
You can't have a
marketing campaign
that you plan out, necessarily.
It's much more
organic than that.
And so what you
really have to do
is focus on the potential value.
And you can have,
after you define
what success would
look like for this API,
you can have an
addressable market
and you can have a target
customer, which actually might
be a target developer partner.
So you can kind of put that
framework loosely in place.
But then once you've done that
from a potential standpoint,
you really just have to
focus on building the best
product that's most enticing
and engaging for the developer
and putting that effort into
it so that you're really
realizing that potential
value that you've established.
ALICIA PATERSON: And
of course, and you
can't plan for innovation.
And to your point
earlier, there's
probably far more innovators
outside the organization
than internally, so
you found some people
doing interesting things
you weren't anticipating.
But of course, being
[INAUDIBLE] set of customers,
being able to try-- get very,
very close to the end user,
to the business
need to developers,
and then be able to interact
quickly on how you support them
with API products.
I think that ability
to iterate quickly,
you'll find where the
value is, and then
you can start building
on top of that.
So the next question.
Erin, with the
benefit of experience,
if you go back to the start
of the Walgreens API program,
is there anything that
you would do differently?
ERIN NEUS-CHEONG: Yeah,
so honestly, I mean,
I'd say not a lot.
And I think you saw
in my story that we
got really lucky,
that we actually
had a lot of the
right pieces in place.
And I think we did a
lot of the right things
from the beginning.
And I understand
that not everyone
might have that good
fortune, to have
all the right things in place.
So I would just
suggest for others,
while I wouldn't
necessarily change,
for another company to try
to replicate as many of those
conditions that I
talked about as you can,
at least to the extent
that you can control it.
So that being said, I
do think that if there
was one thing that I could
do a little bit differently
was maybe engaging
a little bit earlier
with our digital marketing team
about our marketing strategy.
I think there's some really
unique things here about how
you market API programs that I
think we've been still working
through, which is
you really want
the benefit of the program.
You want the appetite and the
engagement for the program,
but the brand that's driving
it isn't your own brand.
And so the considerations
are a little bit different.
And again, I think
we're getting there,
but I think if we
had started earlier,
we may have perfected that dance
a little bit better by now.
ALICIA PATERSON:
It certainly sounds
like you're fortunate
to have great vision
for the organization in
terms of digital goals,
but then also, strong
leadership, right?
Both in your executive level and
your director level that were
able to execute on the plans.
So Erin, how do you
communicate the value of APIs
to business leadership and
to product stakeholders?
ERIN NEUS-CHEONG: Yeah,
so I've definitely
talked about this throughout the
presentation and a little bit
earlier, but I think the
most important part of this
is just speaking
the right language.
So if you're talking
to a marketing person
and you're talking about
things in terms of customer
acquisition, and you
bring to the table
an actual example with
data that shows how you've
been able to bring customers
into becoming customers
that have, through
the API program,
come in and driven broader
value for the company.
And if you're talking to
a P&L owner or a merchant,
you're talking about things in
terms of EBIT and basket size
and how you're driving
value for them.
And when you're talking to
someone on the product team,
you're talking about things
like rapid test and learn
and outside innovation, and how
these developer partnerships
have made our own products
more effective and better
meet the needs of our customers.
ALICIA PATERSON: OK, great.
I think we did touch
on measurements,
but I'll ask this question
because I think this
is from a very practical level.
What do we measure
in your API program?
ERIN NEUS-CHEONG: Yeah, we have
some kind of standard things
that we typically measure,
like the number of partners
that we have for a given API
or the number of transactions
that are standard
across all of them.
And then we have
some unique things
for each that are
applicable to that API,
like the number of rewards
points that have been awarded,
the number of coupons
that have been redeemed,
or the number of prescriptions
that have been refilled.
ALICIA PATERSON:
Right, which is great
because then you're
actually tying the,
I guess, the transactions
on the API level
back to real
business activities.
And so the question was
how do you tie those back
to business benefits?
How do you measure
developer satisfaction?
ERIN NEUS-CHEONG: Yes, so we
have a couple ways that we
measure developer satisfaction.
So we actually have a standard
developer satisfaction survey
that is just like a customer
satisfaction survey.
And that goes out once a year,
and we evaluate the results
from that to help
build a better program.
But beyond that,
I think, again, we
have this really strong
developer evangelist,
and he's out there every day
having meetings with some
of our key developers.
And I think we have a really
good sense and our finger
on the pulse of what our
developers want because
of those frequent interactions.
And almost any significant
developer, partner,
in our ecosystem, we're
constantly asking them
what we can be doing better.
ALICIA PATERSON:
You know, that's
such an important function
I don't see organizations
consider enough.
They sort of leave it as
an after thought almost,
like who's going to
wake up every day
and think about how do I
make it easier for developers
to engage with us [INAUDIBLE].
So it's great that you
have that person in place.
So Erin, how do you
stay close to developers
to ensure an
outside-in perspective
and ensure that you're
API product design is
a strong fit for their needs?
ERIN NEUS-CHEONG: Yeah, so
I think I mentioned this.
I mean, we just have
such a close partnership
on an ongoing basis
with our developers.
And I think not just
listening to what
they're asking for from us
but sort of sharing back
to them the things
that we're thinking of.
And it's really a dialogue.
And so oftentimes we bring
certain partners in very, very
early into the process--
and we've had launch partners
come in even when an API is
in beta--
and I think we
just, together, we
learn so much from each other.
And I think that helps us
understand the developer needs
before we get too
far down the pipeline
and that it is
meeting their needs
and then also meeting our needs.
ALICIA PATERSON: And do
you incentivize developers?
ERIN NEUS-CHEONG: Yes, we do.
So we have a few
ways that we do that.
I think most
notably, we actually,
for a couple of our APIs,
we have a revenue share.
So there is an actual
monetary compensation.
And I think there's other
ways of incentivizing.
Again, the Walgreens
brand is very valuable,
so being able to talk about a
partnership with the Walgreens
brand is something
that is an incentive.
And then finally, those sort of
indirect incentives where we're
enabling a business
metric that that partner
has through the services that
they can get through our APIs.
ALICIA PATERSON: That's awesome.
So actually, I think that's
probably all the time
we have for questions.
So we will make sure to answer
our questions separately
online, so you'll
see responses there.
And we've got
Googlers, as I said,
that are also
answering questions.
So I think that wraps us up.
I'd like to thank
you once again,
everyone, for joining
into our webinar today.
And thank you very much to Erin
for joining us and presenting
your really amazing
Walgreens API product story.
And a reminder that we
have another webcast again
next Tuesday, and we hope
you can join us again then.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]